thank you
[Music]
all right we got a JK viewer a long time
follower
her name's G she's in Australia she was
in the middle of a debate with some
friends at the gym and she asked great
place to fight we could help settle this
debate all right they probably settled
it's been some time but yeah I don't
think they've come to a conclusion it's
a tough one yeah she's right her friends
do they watch the show no okay they're
wrong yeah and they're not patreon
members so [__] them completely so
here's the question we'll back her up
this is what they were arguing about in
the gym okay is it possible for a guy to
have sex with a Thai [__] without it
being gay
hi lady boy this is not a haha question
they really
were seriously I thought it was gonna be
a gym question I was really good
it [__] Waits probably it's a
it's interpret what is a homosexual act
but did she know like if she if he
didn't know then it's not gay he knows
yeah oh because of the penis
I forgot that's
okay so I would argue that if the
[__] had a bikini on didn't know they
had a raging boner underneath okay and
you had oral sex meaning they performed
oral sex on you
and you came and then they went Tada I'm
a [__]
then you're like oh
surprise surprise I didn't know okay I
don't think that's gay that's not gay
enough because you thought it was a
woman you thought it was a woman yes but
okay
but if you knew it was a [__] right
you flip them over they're bent over
they're [__] and then they're doing
anal sex and not only are you anal sex
you reach around grab their boner and
stroke it so they come while you come
I think that's really gay and you know
you know what why because it's almost
like uh you're having sex with a mermaid
it's half Mountain
America
yeah
that's Walt Disney said I think if you
have sex with you're seeking out
specifically ladyboys okay yeah yeah and
you have and that's what I think that's
looking through a catalog and circling
and you're like I don't want a guy I
don't want a girl I want a [__] I
think that's its own category oh
interesting I think it's not gay I don't
think it's straight I think it's the
same category you think it's Asian
appreciation
I think it's I kind of agree I think you
like trans women because I think if
you're looking through the catalog and
then you see dudes like yeah and you see
chicks you're like
then you're really just looking for like
what's the third option
like let's say that you're not a person
in this situation that necessarily you
don't like trans women but you like Thai
lady boys like this just that okay then
you like unicorns you like magical
Spirits I mean we all have different
preferences and different parts of our
lives right for different things so this
could just be a tear preference in their
life or it says transition into
full-blown
[Laughter]
you like a little bit of both
it's gay what
okay waist up Jason Momoa waist down
Paris Hilton I thought you were gonna
say Jason Momoa again
no Jason Momoa
which one is more actually to me which
one is more gay right that's true like
[__] is a man with a vagina or a or a
woman with a penis oh I would say that's
a good argument I'd rather woman with a
penis me too me too
okay because man with the vagina it's
you he wants to be a girl
I'm not thinking that far
I'm just thinking for me I've been
stacked with a man that's yeah but then
he doesn't have a Jason oh okay okay no
but look okay look at this all right
hey dude Imagine John Cena
and then John Cena has a vagina and
you're boning John Cena but then they
all [__] do exactly in order to use
him as a dummy saying that like if John
Cena grew his hair out and lost some
weight do I mean and that little BBL no
no no no no no no no no
because you're no no that's not that's
cheating because it's becoming more
feminine yes yeah but no no
it's cheating because the lady is
from the dealer exactly
no warranty no warranty no upgrades
not fully loaded in the showroom yeah
the [__] right there and there
titties long hair okay that was nice but
I got a big dick
I'm in
well the best part you don't have to
have sex you don't have to touch it
huh you don't have to suck it you don't
have to touch it how am I gonna like
have have sex if I don't have to touch
it you make out and do everything else
and then when they try to [__] you with
it you go I'm not ready
I'm not ready
hold up I'm making out I'm thinking of
her penis huh the whole time I'm making
up I'm thinking she's got a penis yeah
okay but if you okay
John Cena doesn't have a penis yeah but
I can't get my dick hard if John Cena
right there with us so you should have
just covered your shot with a blanket
yeah
[Laughter]
have sex with a guy with the [__]
giant pecks six-pack hairy big [__]
quads but he has a vagina yeah
he's calling it a guy dude what the [__]
is wrong with you
versus a slender lady
boobies long hair smells nice but a big
dick guys
option
[Laughter]
we got him
we gotta move move
oh my God would you believe then Colleen
let's say you're dating a guy okay you
guys are talking about the past yeah
your turn now and then he says he says
oh you know what yeah I've been with
women all my life one time one time I
had sex with a Thai lady boy does is
that a problem
[Laughter]
the context beyond that like was he
aware yes like it was intentional
intentional it was for fun
and it's sometimes not fair because a
lot of the Thai lady boys look hotter
than the girls in Thailand sometimes
what did he do specifically
specifically
hold everything there you go the whole
shebang
though
garlic butter
you get everything but suck suck their
dick that's nice is that okay yeah he
[__] the butt [__] them
what else [__] but can we get a better
picture of let's get some romantic terms
[__] milk the cow cow that's the best
we'll get what do you think yeah
does that make you feel does it make you
feel uneasy if he's like but I'm not
into that that just did it once that's
one time yeah he goes you know what I
was doing I was just I would ask him
like what his State of Mind was during
that I said clearer he was like
yeah
he's enjoyed it but he wouldn't go back
but if he was like I was just very
open-minded during that time I got it
out of my sister it's like if you
watched wave of the water it's like yeah
it's a good movie you know what if he
was like
my head is like little tiny red flag
every time you guys say something so
maybe maybe no maybe what if he's like I
was I was curious about being gay but I
couldn't go full for her yeah yeah cut
the baby step into it it's like when you
eat foie gras right you don't eat all
the time you just do it for special
occasions okay so all you guys would be
okay with just
going and doing that no that's why
okay I'm trying to be in the frame of
mind
[Laughter]
one thing that happened to you guys that
was a decision that you made and you
opened up to your current wife or your
girl should I expect me the way the uh
but my perverted mind if she likes me
that she likes me yes but I think I
cracked your code I think I cracked your
code okay because to me there's a lot of
like weirdness with that because of uh
buying sex or whatever what if he
explored with homosexuality with the man
who is in the [__] and just tried
making now
whatever and then he goes you know I had
some gay experiences
I have some gay experiences but I
realized I'm not that gay and I tested
it out yeah yeah that and I was curious
that one and then if he said it that way
we'll go with that choice
what do you think
I don't want to answer a question
because I have a theory it depends on
how much how invested I am in this
person and when he told me because if a
girl said I had lesbian experiences I'll
be like tell me well that's just because
it's like it's viewed differently six
months in six months anytime oh no we're
good one year one year five years five
years Jesus no but the guys are married
and then he tells you it happened
he tells you in the middle of the vows
how about this and then I tell them well
I actually have a big dick so this works
out great it's Dion full you're talking
Dion Cole Dion Cole has this experience
it's not my love of my life guys
I like okay what if the uncle just came
clean was like I'm just I'm hoping you
can accept me
I'm hoping to saying a red flag because
I [__] about [__] guys
[Laughter]
when he said to like that you're like
okay cool yeah I thought it was a dick
man but I realized I just love [__]
that when you say it like that oh man
dude I think you all is forgiving
it is right the delivery can determine
yeah how confident he is right right I
thought it was a thick guy you know I'm
like uh yeah I feel like you're not
quite sure about yourself that has a lot
to do with it that's the ultimate test
is like it doesn't matter if other guys
think that's gay what matters is if the
next girl that you want to convince that
you're straight if she says no you're
gay right because I mean think about
this like how many I mean how many
relationships have like a girl's been in
married to her husband for years and
then he ends up being gay and then he
leaves it happens it happens yeah a lot
more than you actually think
so I think that would be like the main
concern is like I don't want to invest
my time into this one person for it to
be completely run away with a man okay
he's gonna run away with a man you
married a guy
this guy gets in trouble goes to jail
for like five years
in jail he comes back out
and he's like I only did it with Slender
dudes but I was thinking about you the
whole time and they look just like you
oh that's sweet do you go
yeah what how do you feel about that um
well when I have questions like what did
he do to get to jail
he got framed for something yeah well
because it wasn't his fault he got
framed for tax fraud no he is not his
fault but he got so horny and lonely in
there but what what in jail it's like a
doggy dog world so either he gets boned
or he bones back yeah really if he gets
out and
no
even if even if he was thought if he
thought about you the whole time no
really because also like how how can I
how can that be proven it's just his
words did his boy do the phone call
because it's more so it's it's the words
versus the actions for me he asked the
cell mate to call you'd be like he was
thinking about you the whole time
it confirmed it
yeah
when he was [__] me
named had it in prison come on oh that's
good please don't ever
come on bro I'm getting colder with her
I think we don't know Colleen we don't
know what she likes so that would always
stand in the way the history of like
having a little experimentation with
[__]
yeah I think so is it because ladyboys
are pretty hot they're hotter than me
kind of competitive feel threatened a
little threatened yeah it's always in
the back of her mind
can never provide him dick the way that
he could and then like sometimes they're
hanging out and he's like babe we should
go to Thailand she's like no we're not
going to [__]
is that is there is there a way Curry
what is there a way to jack off a
[__] in a heterosexual way yeah it's
like six ways go ahead
[Laughter]
um
just thinking okay you have to think so
bad
so this is what I'm thinking so I
recently watched this podcast clip of
these two guys that are on Trend trend
is an extreme steroid and Trent is
notorious for making you sexually
deviant like whatever your big shoe yeah
what you're naturally like
it doesn't get you off anymore so you
have to do crazy [__] so guys and girls
usually cheat and then the dude that was
on the podcast he says when he's on
Trend he doesn't know why he only wants
to Bone ugly chicks what I have to be
the uglier the better so it makes you
like way deviant off your normal course
right and the girls that were like
where's he on trip
[__] so I don't know why that is so like
the mindset I guess that it puts you in
it wants you to have like the dirty
nasty [__] right so I'm like if you're a
dirty nasty boy could you be in the
mindset of still being heterosexual and
I'm boning this [__] and I'm just
jacking off a woman's penis not a man's
penis yeah woman's penis yeah it
functions immediately when that's 23
baby yeah I think maybe
okay that's kind of like
a lesbian scene with a strap-on that's
hot
nobody wants to agree if you're late
if your lady had a strap on and you're
boning her if you stroke the strap on a
couple times oh is that hetero I guess
it's not a real dick I guess might as
well be
I don't want to touch a dildo and jack
it off oh if it has a mushroom but you
haven't been on this trend though what
if you're just like you just want the
weird nasty I'mma just [__] in my mouth
that's chimpan trend
the other person
some yeah guys watching Dixie got a
shout out oh [__]
hey man
how do you know my name man you know
what it is there's people who believe
gayness is your past some believe it's
your present and others believe it's
your future intent
there's actually a category where
because some people go you're gay
because of what you did in the past some
people go you're gay because of what you
want to do but you won't admit it and
some people just go you're gay yeah I
get that one lost and some people say
you're gay because you just like Star
Wars
true
I have your lightsaber then we know yeah
yeah yeah
there is a term like where they say men
that have sex with men but their head
they're straight men that have sex with
men that's the whole thing yeah he's all
about that I'm all about that me and my
wife have arguments about this yeah
because I'm like those guys like they
they don't say they're gay but they like
having sex with men they prefer then
they don't prefer that they'd probably
do both but like I'd say they yeah so I
[Laughter]
view homosexuality
is it is it sexual acts that make you
homosexual or is it your love for a man
in a romantic way that makes you
homosexual because that's what that's
what I think it is because then your
love forever because there's homosexual
men that don't have anal sex like
doesn't sound like a party but they'll
be in long-term relationships with them
with each other but they're like it's a
lot of work you gotta [__] do the
cleaning and then you gotta [__] it's
like dirty what about you do the
opposite you marry a guy you don't have
sex with a guy but you only have sex
with women there's so much going on what
happened what do you call that that
that's called roommates
like say me and Bart got married okay
yeah but like we don't have any sex at
all we only have sex with other women
wait what
I marry Bart
me and jumping in a 15-year marriage we
don't [__] with other chicks you're
attracted you're attracted to Bart
emotion that's called breasts they're
attracted to women sexually yeah what
happens yeah you get it that's called
ideal baby that's the idea
you get to live together yeah and you
get to send the women home yeah yeah and
then we have sex and then you know yeah
I think that's I've been thinking about
that a lot and I'm like that's that's
kind of yeah
later on you're gonna go hey we should
get a place together we should look at
some places apart we combine our
combined finances together go on Zillow
real quick
nah that's the thing none of us will be
on Zillow all the time dude all of our
ladies are always on [__] Zillow it's
crazy so let's go around the room yes or
no is it gay the original question is it
possible for a guy to have sex with the
Thai [__] without it being gay Bart
yes I say it's its own category okay
Jason I agree with Nick no you can't oh
my bad I I also I also agree with Nick
and Jason go ahead
if you're a man
and there's a dick involved it's pretty
gay pretty good not 100 but pretty Steve
uh I think it's a gay act oh yeah but
yeah kind of more I kind of would you
guys I think if you if he didn't no no
he didn't prior he knew that that's why
he's seeking it up
yeah I think we're all I think we're all
right because is it it's it's
homosexuality it's it's the same yes
exactly so it's okay it's gay by like
the terminology yeah the definition it's
a human penis
is it still I forgot what we what our
opinion was
now the categories were kind of messed
together on these I think you just like
ladyboys there but we all agree that if
you didn't know and you still did it and
you never detected then you got then you
got food yeah yeah you got Copperfield
in yeah yeah but I mean it's is it a
scam because you got to come
yeah
it's just I got to answer your question
G from Australia and all you guys at the
gym
what did I say I forgot he said not gay